هذا وكان وصف عمران خان الحكومه
الباكستانيه بحكومه اللصوص داعيه ناصر
هويلا مواصله الكفاح اذا ما تم قتله او
سجنه
انا احارب معركتكم لقد حاربت طوال حياته
وساواصل ذلك لكن اذا حدث لي شيء ما ودخلت
السجن او قتلت فعليكم اثبات ان هذه الامه
ستستمر في كفاحها بدون عمران خان فهذه
حكومه لصوص ويجب ان لا تقبلوا بذلك ابدا
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من اسلام اباد
رؤوف حسن مستشار رئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه
سابق عمران خان اهلا بك معنا سياده
المستشار في الواقع نود الوقوف بما وردكم
او بحسب ما وردكم عن التهمه
بالتحديد التي وجهها او وجهت لي ريس وزراء
عمرا خان ما التهمه
هو المتهم
باخذ هديه منحت لهم من
قبل احد الضيوفه خلال زيارته
وهنالك مكان مخصص لايداعي الهدايا
والاشخاص الذين تقدم لهم هذه الاداء الذين
هم الحق القانوني لدفع مبلغ محدد واخذ
الهديه وعمران خان فعل ذلك واخذ بعض
الهدايا من المخزن بعد دفع المبلغ والان
او يتهمون بانه واخذ هذه الهدايا وحتى هذا
غير قانوني حتى وان كان باعها فلا يوجد اي
اساس لهذه التهمه وفيما يخص القواعد في
قلنا ان سجل هدايا تشاكانا يجب ان تكون
علنيه والحكومه الان جعلت علنيا قائمه
الهدايا بين عام 2022
فكل الشخص
كان رئيس وزراء او رئيسك كلهم استلموا
الهدايا فلا يوجد اي اساس لهذه التهمه
احياء قضيه حالها الكثير من القضايا التي
يوم غدا المحكمه ولكن السيد رؤوف اليوم
راي رئيس وزراء سابق عمران خان يتحدث الى
انصاره عن
وجوب ان يكونوا متوحدين حول انسجن او قتل
هل هناك تهديدات ترده في هذا الاطار
كانت هناك محاوله اغتيال اذا ما تذكرتم
وحاولوا قتله هو اصيب الثلاث الرصاصات في
رجله اليمنى ولا يزال يعاني منها فليس هذه
فحسبه هنالك محاوله اغتيال ايضا في السابق
وبما انهم مواجهته في الساحه السياسيه
وخسر كل الانتخابات
ضده في 11 الشهر الماضيه منذ استلمها
السلطه فبالتالي يحاولون التخلص منه
نهائيا وهذا ما نخشه في حزبنا ولهذا السبب
يجب ان يكون هذا حاضرين للغايه اذا ما ذهب
وقف امام المحكمه وهذا هو مصدر وكل هذا
الجدل لم يمنع حتى الحمايه الامنيه وهو
حقه بصفته الرئيس وزراء الاسبق فقد ازاحوا
عنه الحمار الامنيه والحكومات حمل اي
مسؤوليه والحزب يجب ان
ليضمن سلامته وامنه وبعيدا عن كي لا تعرض
لمحاوله اغتيالاخرى هذا الحزب وهذه الدوله
لا تستطيع ان تتحمل خسارته هو المفروض
اليوم بحسب تصريحات وزير الداخليه سيتم
اعتقاله الى حين المحاكمه ما الذي حدث هل
اعتقل وما الذي حضرتموه مع فريق الدفاع
بالنسبه للمحاكمه لديكم ثقه في القضاء سيد
رؤوف
المحكمه قالت انه يجب ان يمثل امامها
الثامنه عشره من هذا الشهر اليوم هو
الرابع عشر فما الغرض من اعتقاده اليوم
لماذا يريدون يزوجون بالسجن قبل اربعه
ايام منذ قبل مثوله في المحكمه 17 او
كربما يطلبون منه المثوله في 18 وكان
لوحده فالسؤال حواله وليس سؤال عداله بل
هو النوايا وراء هذه المحاوله اعتقاله قبل
مثوله امام المحكمه نحن نشعر بان هنالك
ويريدون التخلص منه بشكل نهائي لانما
المستحيل في هذا الوقت ان يواجهونهم في
الانتخابات
والحركه الاساسيه من قبل المحكمه وكافه
الحياه المتعالفه مع اهلهم
يحاولون ان يطرح حتى على الانتخابات ولكن
نريد تفويض اكبر من الشعب ونحن بانتظار
الانتخابات ولكن الحكومه تحاول عدم عقد
الانتخابات
وهنالك حدث غير مسبوق في الباكستان وعمره
خان حقق المكاسب لهذا يريدون التخلص منهم
فلهذا نحن اتخذوا للاجراءات الاحترازيه
فالسؤالك عن القضاء او عدالته القضاء هو
الامر الاخير لباكستاني كل المؤسسات
الاخرى اصبحت فاسده الى مرحله لا عوده
ونحن لثقتنا بالنظام القضائي
لقد
تحدث مع محكمه اسلام اباد واسمعنا قضيه مع
غد وكلنا امل انه مره اخرى سيحصل على
الكفاله فاذا ما اعتقلت فسيعتقل لغايه
صباح الغد وبعد ذلك
المحكمه في الثامنه عشر عندما يكون مطلوبه
منه يعني اعتقاله لن يتم اليوم بحسب كلامك
سيتم ذلك صباح غد ولكن هناك من يروج لفكره
بانه غادر محل سكناه الى حين مثوله امام
المحكمه يوم 18 تؤكد لنا ذلك
المحكمه الطلبه تمثلها امامها يوم الثامن
عشر اعتقل اليوم واقول لا حاجه لاعتقاله
لانهم لو طلبوا منه الا كان الحضاره شخصيا
يوم 18 يوم الثامن عشر واعتقد انه بعد
اتخاذ الاجراءات الاحترازيه الامنيه
وكان امام المحكمه امام اربعه محاكم في
سنوات قبل ايام اذهب الى سنابات ومثل امام
محكمه فلا يوجد اي سبب
للاعتقاد انه لن يذهب في الثامن عشر لا
يوجد اي عداله باعتقاله اليوم قبل جلسه
السمع
لهذا السبب نحن نرى ان هنالك نوايا خبيثه
وراء هذه الحركه وضحت الفكره وشكرك جزيلا
شكرا على المشاركه حسن مستشار رئيس
الوزراء الباكستانيه سابق عمران شكرا لك